هي ما زالت في الحقيقه ولكن طبعا معظم
المطارات التي تتاثر بها كثير هي المطارات
الكبيره مثل مطارات اتلانتا او مطار سان
فرانسيسكو او مطار شيكاغو وخاصه الرحلات
التي تتجه نحو همم الولايات الشماليه التي
ضربتها العاصفه لاسيما المحيطه او التي
تضم منطقه البحيرات التي تلقت ال- ال-
القوه الكبرى من هذا الانفجار الكبير
القطبي الكبير الذي وصلنا نحن هنا همم في
همم فرجينيا وفي ميرندا همم تاثيره في
الحقيقه ولكن همم اليوم كان هناك تحسن
بالنسبه لاعاده جدول الرحلات هناك الغاء
وتاخير لبعد الرحلات لدي بعض الارقام
تاخير همم نحو ثلاثه الاف 1650 رحله
والغاء
1937 رحله بينما كان يوم الجمعه كان هناك
الغاء مقارنه همم ثلاثه همم الغاء ثلاث
الاف 480 رحله هنا في مطار ايه رونالدو
المحادي للعاصمه واشنطن من 500 تم الغائها
تاجيلها يوم الجمعه يوم الذروه الذي يسبق
ليله عيد الميلاد المجيد الان نتحدث عن
بعض الرحلات التي ايضا الغت بالنسبه
للرحلات المتوجهه نحو الشمال لكن كانت
المفارقه ان ااه سالنا احد العاملين هنا
واحد المسؤولين قال لنا انه هناك رحله تم
الغائها تتجه نحو الجنوب نحو فلوريدا هذا
امر غريب لانه فلوريدا صحيح فيها موجه برد
قارس ولكن لا يوجد عصير ولا همم ثلوج همم
معظم الكما ذكرنا تفضل
يعني المشهد من خلفك هو في مطار رونلد
ريجن لا اعتقد ان
المشهد سيتاثر كثير لانه حركه السفر ب25
يوم عيد الميلاد عاده لا تكون بزخامه 24
و23 اذا ممكن للكاميرا ان تسلط الضوء من
من حولك يعني او من خلفك
ساتحرك بالكاميرا كما قلت ريما اليوم لم
يكن هناك ضغط كبير لان كما قلنا همم معظم
الضغط كان في يومين الثالث والعشرين
والرابع والعشرين من ليله عيد الميلاد
كانت العاصفه قويه جدا همم
[موسيقى]
نعم
ويحاول ان يساعدني
توجه قليلا الى الامام
طيب فيما انت تتحدث ونرى مشاهد المسافرين
يوم عيد الميلاد عاده لا تكون كبيره ولكن
هناك الغاءت الفتني حسين انه اتصلت ببعض
الاصدقاء من ميامي من بعض الوقت حتى ما
يامن لاعاده تقسم دبي مثلا في برد ولابسين
كنزات همم اخبرني عن الولايات التي تاثرت
بالفعل يعني نستطيع ان نقول ريما الولايات
التي نجت من هذا الانفجار القطبي من
الثلوج تاثرت برياحها العاتيه في الحقيقه
يعني ان يتم تح- ااا توجيه تحذيرات الى
سكان فلوريدا المعروفه بانها ولايه دافئه
هذا امر غريب ومستغرب همم بسبب هذه
البروده القارصه ايضا ادت الى ضغط كبير
على شبكات الكهرباء ومحطات تبيض الكهرباء
بسبب همم استخدام المواطنين في هذه
الولايات غير المعتدين في الحقيقه على هذه
الموجه البارده همم ادوات التدفئه
والتسخير ما ادى الى وجود ضغط على محطات
التوليد الكهرباء وايضا انقطاع الكهرباء
عن عدد كبير من الناس همم الان احنا هنا
في الولايات المتحده يوجد بحسب احصاءات
رسميه
175,000 منزل يعانون من انقطاع الكهرباء
طبعا كان العدد اكبر يوم الجمعه حيث كان
هناك مليون و500,000 منزل عانوا من انقطاع
الكهرباء
قلنا العاصفه هدات اا قليلا همم بتاثيرها
هذا قليلا البارحه كانت درجات الحراره هنا
في همم شمال فيرجينيا وفي ميرلاند نحو 16
تحت الصفر اليوم نحن نتحدث عن اثنين تحت
الصفر كما قلت انا الان في هنا في المطار
الحركه اليوم شبه عاديه هناك تاخيرات و
تاجيل ولكن حسب ما قيل لنا هذا التاجيل
تاجيل طبيعي بعضها خاصه الرحلات المتوجهه
نحو الشمال هي تم تاجيله همم بسبب العاصفه
التي تضرب ولايه شمال ولا سينما منطقه همم
غرب همم
ولايه غرب همم نيويورك وتحديدا مطري الجون
افنديا في هذه الولايه
همم هناك كل شيء مغلق الثلوج تغطي همم
المدرج ولكن بشكل عام في الولايات الباقيه
هناك برد ولكن الرحلات عادت كما كانت